is it possible that the universe isn't
expanding but that we're all just
shrinking at a constant rate all the way
to nothingness seriously wouldn't that
look like expansion from our perspective
well that's a great question I have to
think about that sure everything was
shrinking but at the rate the universe
is expanding I don't know it seems like
we would have shrunk
yeah everything in the universe would
have to shrink but here's the problem is
the universe itself that's expanding not
the things in the right race we're not
growing right you example for American
so so I have to think more about that
yeah I bet that'd be a fun little sci-fi
cartoon yeah I'm gonna say physically
based on not knowing anything I don't
think that's the case but I like the
idea yeah it's a fun idea to think about
that sure we'll get back to there be
shrinking
could we be shrinking at a rate that
appears that the universe is it yeah
because all of our measuring rods would
have to be shrinking with us well we
could be everything to be shrinking
right but that'd be an extraordinary
thing if it were happening it's not more
extraordinary than just something
expanding yeah things expand all the
time yes oh yeah pink we are
extraordinary explanation and and this
sounds like something they would have
thought in the Middle Ages I go with
yeah and then murder to anyone who's
like I don't know I think it's expanding
don't be an idiot we're all streaking
we're gonna murder you we're going to
liberate your soul yeah exactly yeah you
relax